[Musique]
la secrétaire d'état marlène schiappa a
clôturé sa visite à la réunion à la
préfecture ce matin dans le cadre du
grenelle des violences conjugales à la
réunion elle a assisté à la restitution
des travaux débuter le 3 septembre
dernier qui vise à faire des
propositions au gouvernement afin
d'améliorer la lutte contre ces
violences
d'abord il y avait des demandes de
moyens financiers je suis venu avec huit
cent mille euros supplémentaires pour
les autres maires dont 135 fléché
spécialement sur la réunion et puis il
ya des gens que je travaillais cela
j'étais moins pour la restitution du
grenelle des violences conjugales mais
ça fait depuis le 3 septembre et même
avant puisqu'il y avait des dispositifs
avant mais depuis le 3 septembre dans le
cadre du grenelle des violences
conjugales des experts des experts des
associations des représentants de la caf
des élus de tous les bords politiques
des représentants de la police de la
justice de toutes les institutions se
sont réunis en travaillant fait des
préconisations qui me semblent tous très
intéressante qu'elle soit nationale ou
qu'elle soit vraiment là pour apporter
des réponses à la spécificité de la
réunion et donc on va faire en sorte de
les mettre en oeuvre
la séquence est achevée par la signature
d'une convention avec le conseil
départemental de la ring une convention
très important parce qu'avec des points
demandés par l'ensemble des associations
lors dû gagner grenelle qui a vu ici en
préfecture premier point en double
nombre d'assistants sociaux pour
l'accueil donc des femmes victimes dans
les commissariats et dans les
gendarmeries à la réunion nous en seront
à neuf dès le mois de janvier 2020 avec
un objectif d'athènes 15 dans les deux
ans qui viennent
deuxième mesure très importante on à
39,19 local créolisé qui va fonctionner
24 heures sur 24 pour qu' il est une
réponse rapide et une compréhension de
la demande des femmes victimes troisième
point l'éviction du conjoint violent
c'est inscrit dans la loi mais souvent
ce sont les femmes qui ont la double
peine elles doivent quitter maison avec
enfants elle serait dans une autre école
être en hébergement d'urgence
et là avec
la justice les procureurs nous pourrions
faire en sorte que l'homme lui même
puisse être en 8es ou en structure
d'accueil pour laisser les femmes et les
enfants dans la maison familiale avec un
suivi psychologique pour les hommes pour
que la récidive soient moindres qu ils
ne reproduisent pas eux mêmes les
schémas de violence que parfois ils ont
connu une autre mesure également très
importante c'est la possibilité pour les
femmes d'avoir la possibilité de quitter
le département c'est à dire la
territorialité
quand une femme est sortie de prison du
conjoint violent ce sens menacé et a
peur il ya une demande qui émane des
associations pour qu'elles puissent être
accompagnés financièrement pour quitter
la réunion quand elle en a besoin
à l'issue de l'ensemble des travaux
engagés dans les départements de france
le gouvernement devrait dévoiler une
série de mesures le 25 novembre
[Musique]